the shutdown also means thousands of
intelligence community workers are on
furlough
we spoke with CIA director Mike Pompeo
we asked about North Korea and other
ongoing threats to America's national
security he also explained why the
shutdown is not necessarily a sign of
weakness how does a government shutdown
affect national security it won't impact
our operations here at CIA we're gonna
continue crushing our adversaries
whether the government's open or closed
we do hope it gets opened back up but
for today and tomorrow and for the few
days ahead of us we're going to continue
to do the things we need to do these
government shutdowns those signal
dysfunction in government and some
people in the National Security arena
say that kind of dysfunction is one of
the biggest threats to u.s. national
security how important is it for
Congress to get this right yeah look I
served in Congress so I've seen this
from another role I'm not sure I agree
that it signals dysfunction the American
people having complicated discussions
about their priorities I think that's
entirely appropriate in a democracy as
director of the Central Intelligence
Agency Mike Pompeo faces a world worth
of national security threats perhaps
none is urgent doors murky as North
Korea's nuclear advances this September
kim jeong-hoon detonated a sixth nuclear
bomb we know that was coming yes here's
here's here's what we can say we can
always identify that the program is
continuing we'll never know the exact
nature of what's taking place we'll
never know the exact moment that they're
going to continue but the core risk that
the policymakers needed to know was that
North Korea's nuclear weapons program is
continuing to expand advanced become
more powerful more capable more reliable
each of those things had been shared
with policy makers so to be clear how
close is Kim jong-un to being able to
deliver a nuclear attack to the
territorial United States a handful of
months but correct me if I'm wrong I do
believe you have used that phrase more
than six months ago you said a handful
I hope to be able to say that a year
from now as well the United States
governor is working diligently to extend
that time line well in our next hour
more of our interview with CIA director
Mike Pompeo how he delivers the daily
intelligence briefing to President Trump
lots to talk about so we've got more
just ahead here on CBS